the gap between police and the community
that's a topic that's heavy on the minds
of a lot of people so tonight several
police chiefs met to have an open
discussion on how people can trust
police and let them know they're on
their side victoria saha has their
message topics in tonight's discussion
varied from how the community can trust
law enforcement officers to methods ccsd
uses to stop violence and how students
do not become repeat offenders
what is he going to have to go against
every day and
and realize that
he may have a target on his back a
powerful question coming from a young
girl who wants a different future for
her community we are you you are us just
because we wear a badge in uniform
doesn't make us any different than you
thursday evening's police forum welcomed
open dialogue with minorities in our
community and several police chiefs
including ccsd police chief addressing
violent offenders in school minor
misdemeanor crimes are considered focus
acts
where officers can utilize alternatives
to arrest chief michael blackeye with
ccsd pd says the alternative to arrest
is to protect the youth from the justice
system as much as possible it's not
about arrest it's not about
how we handle an incident or you know
what we're involved in it's about our
communication with our students
trying to
get them on a path to you know be
successful adults he says if they're
introduced to the criminal justice
system at the wrong age it can lead them
back into prison when they get older so
far this school year they have issued
1500 alternative to arrests whereas
previous years it's only been a few
hundred
the youth it looked like they really
learned from tonight's discussion all
departments agreed there needs to be
more work that has to be done and they
want to engage in the community more to
let everyone know they're just like you
and i live from the newsroom victoria
saha live local now